hey everybody I'm Dave joined by Oscar
deus hello we are we played some games
the Xbox ID event and we saw five that
we thought were the most interesting so
we're going to rattle off what we liked
what we dislike what we thought about
these five games and hopefully when they
come out you guys can try yourselves
first one is Tacoma I didn't get to play
it myself but you had some hands-on with
the correct yes that's right yeah so
tacoma sort of the follow-up I guess too
gone home and it's very much that style
of game like it feels very very similar
it's got that sort of same Irina that
you have when you when you first come
home in gone home but the problem I mean
it was a hard game to demo I suppose but
it didn't have that personal touch that
you immediately felt when when you sort
of first come back in gone home and you
enter this house you sort of even
without knowing who this person is the
playing or any of the people mentioned
in you know the notes that you find you
it was immediately personal because
you're coming back to a house you know
and you've got something you can relate
to yeah exactly where as this is sort of
like a space station where it's very
alien to us and although it's got the
same airiness in the same sort of mood I
guess to gone home it didn't quite have
that same personal touch one thing i
will say like pressing things in that
game was really satisfying for citizen
like you know that sort of weird
inherent like primal satisfaction you
have from pressing a button on a lift
that had that in spades I have no idea
why but yeah it it looked promising i
guess but i didn't quite click with it
in the same way that I did with gone
home which I thought was was amazing and
also like the these audio logs for some
reason you have to stay in the room that
they're being played so it sort of
hinders your exploration because you
have to stay where that audio log is
because it's not only an audio log
there's also these AR sort of I don't
know movies I guess right I did see you
getting distracted during some of them
like pulling letters off Wars and
throwing like turns around and there was
obviously a moment where you were
playing playing basketball but I mean I
was watching you playing it I by great
does seem like a hard game
to demo especially when it's so story
driven and those demos really they only
give you a hint of that but like from
what you played do you think you're
gonna play more of it I'll check it out
when it comes out like I think it's a
hard thing to show off in a 10 minute
demo so it's sort of unfair to judge it
really need to play the whole thing
before I can give an accurate
representation of it but but yeah it
promising I would say well from one
extreme to like storage story telling
and relaxation to another extreme of
like visceral satisfaction and violence
ruiner I thoroughly enjoyed ruiner as
did I it's got Liam real cool it's got
like the DNA of hotline Miami yep and I
think it's taken parts of hotline Miami
and accentuate them and kind of left
some of them behind it didn't feel quite
as frustrating or puzzle II as some of
the moments of hotline miami is yeah
more it's trying to make you use your
abilities to create like flow so you can
like dash new shields and the vibe that
i got from it is that you use those in
like a like a ballet with each other to
like go through and destroy rooms I
using these slo-moes to dash like that
away from mines but it was it was such
visceral satisfaction but it still had
the like an quite intense difficulty
curve that hotline Miami had yeah yeah
that and that that it was very very
tricky that I struggled a lot when I
first played it one thing I didn't like
about it was actually its or piled on
this of new mechanics and power-ups real
quick and I don't know whether that was
just the demo or whether that's going to
be the same in the full game but I
really really enjoyed the first level
for example where you just basically got
a crowbar you know going around
battering folk and it's like that was
really really cool and then sort of the
next level you get a gun in the next
level you get shield in the next level
you get a dash and it's like it become
became very complicated very quickly see
I kind of actually liked that that threw
you into the deep end and isn't trying
to hold back because that's that is also
something that hotline Miami did it was
like this is what you do this games got
got like three or four buttons go and
trash some levels yeah but probably
thinks that maybe there's going to be
some levels that
create kind of like a scenario where you
only get mellie weapons yes I my husband
I manage the devil you'll only get guns
to try and balance it out but there was
it felt that was quite a good balance
between gunplay and mellow stuff like
some enemies seem to be weaker against
my lip maybe no weaker but some
situations called for Mellie more yeah
yeah then guns did and like the basic
pistol you got the ruiner isn't actually
very good despite its sharing the name
of the game so you're like picking up
weapons as you go it when you it's like
up the that that moment where if you
nail something so perfectly there's like
there's no other feeling like it yeah I
was very satisfying when it with this is
him off cyberpunk aesthetic there's like
part hotline Miami part like if you've
listened to carpenter brut a listen to
that style of music it's very like
techno noir and cyberpunk can just
heavily intense and when I played it I
came out of it I was like I'm lucky yeah
it was exhausting today was an event but
at the same time I just I just wanted to
play more next game we looked at that
was a that was quite interesting was a
sexy brutale which is also one of the
greatest names ever it is a pretty cool
name i'll give it that I think it's got
one of the most unique selling points I
hate them I hate this word but it's very
novel novel it's very novel so
patronizing I fully fully like endorse
it so this game and the way the dev
picture to me he said the game is set in
like nine minute bursts but like the
game takes like eight hours right so you
are a priest and everyone has been kind
of possessed by these evil masks and
you're in the sexy blue tile it's a
casino everyone's being murdered and you
need to prevent these murders and what
happens you go through the day and at
the end of the day the time rewinds back
to 12 back to midday right so you learn
things by going for your days again and
again again kind of like Groundhog's Day
style and then when time goes back you
you know what to do you've unlocked some
puzzles you can get items you save
certain people get their powers like we
see here the guy that you saw the start
got shot so what neither the
days we wound you can find the gun and
says okay I can't really do anything
with the gun you explore take the game
in and work out like how do i prevent
this shooting and alter this timeline we
can see you're spying on him through the
door he's in a safe and he will he will
drop a blank so you're kind of piecing
together your own puzzle little bit
after a little bit and as you've like
recognize things going through the level
that's when you rewind time you've got
the M the benefit of all that knowledge
to have found the blank cartridge here
so you know how to affect the future by
getting the gun that he was originally
shot with putting a blank and then
changing the outcome so in these nine
minute bursts you explore like the
entirety of the casino you start saving
more and more people it's what we're
told is that you can't save like
everyone okay in like a in one go or you
need to kind of set in a set an action a
certain number of events where everyone
gets saved and you you break this curse
it's kind of like a chain reaction right
yeah they've said it's basically
although this demo was almost like a
self-contained thing the full game would
be more like you have to solve one
puzzle which then saves another person
which then changes the outcome as Nobles
let you see here like he wasn't able to
shoot him because he's got a blank and
then you get like an audio cue and you
realize that time has been altered it
was an extremely interesting way to like
tell a story and keep a game fresh like
especially when they've got that that
time constraint of just a few minutes
where you get to have that same you're
playing through the same hours in the
game the same 12 hours but something
different happens every time and with a
learning curve like that you can you can
make as many mistakes as you want you
can screw up as many times as you want
because you've got the advantage of
actually being able to go back in time
like actually revisit your mistakes it
was it was it took me by surprise but
it's such a like such a great idea and
it must have been a nightmare than to
execute but not even a higher they did
it they've managed to create this is
wonderful looking game like it
a game that you're excited and
interesting to be in like a incredible
gameplay concept and I just SAT there my
brain was just like over clogs trying to
think of all the ways that I can start
affecting timelines and doing new and
interesting stuff and saving people I
that out of all of these this is
probably the one I'm most excited for to
get to finally get my hands on awesome
so this games got a lot of press
recently rhyme we played it and I wasn't
hugely impressed unfortunately there was
I day I I went in full of optimism
thinking okay like I've heard a lot
about this game let's actually see
what's what's going on so you you wake
up on an island the game kind of just
what we were dropped into the demo is
like okay here's rhyme go for it it
doesn't really tell you what to do where
to go yeah it tells you which I am
completely fine with yeah completely
fine with but it had some issues for me
and had some issues like when we were
playing the person that stood out the
frame rate oh it was atrocious this
frame rate I'm not sure how well it's
like capturing because obviously this
video will be exploited at the same
frame rate and it was captured a certain
frame rate but it wasn't good yeah we
were playing on xbox one and you know we
should stress is it was an early build
its yet like the final you know retail a
copy of the game but yeah it did not
perform great the other thing that
actually surprised me was the the thing
I was most encouraged by about Ryan
before I played it was its art style
unlike at times it can really really
beautiful rewrite and colorful I
actually thought in motion it looked
kind of dull compared to the trailers
and the screenshots light seen it does
it does look best when it's like it's
got its vistas but i enjoyed liked
things things like this this this is a
little puzzle we're like a bore is
blocking your way and the environment
gives you all the visual clues that you
need to get past this border you go and
find an orange you can see the bores and
it's kids eating oranges or grapefruits
where these things are and the
environment and the visuals are giving
you every hint you need to know to
actually solve a puzzle that's my
favorite way puzzles are done yeah Oh
games it's like it's got like Dark Souls
vibe
I swear its warning you of things by
just giving you like simple small hints
yeah sure um don't hold my hand let me
explore and figure out for myself and
that is something that rhyme seems to do
like pretty well yeah definitely and
also without language as well that I
spoke to the developer afterwards and he
basically told me that they wanted to
create this game and this character as
well to be sort of like a blank slate
like they wanted it to be deliberately
ambiguous where you are what nationality
the character is like what gender the
character is what race the character is
like they wanted it to be a complete
blank slate which I thought was a really
interesting way of doing it but the
counter-argument to that is if you're
making a blank slate there is no
character there so it'll be interesting
to see how that pans out and whether
that gets any development in the full
game hopefully again this is a tricky
one to really get a sense of in a small
preview environment yeah but I'm hoping
that character comes from like his is
well their surroundings the world things
like that I'm I'm optimistic still again
I think it's the kind of game that you
need to just like sit down sink into
really kind of immerse yourself into
interlayer this like honestly quite
beautiful world instead of being unlike
a time constraint of like oh I need to
see this I need to see that if I was in
my living room and I could just relax
and they take in this like massive open
world and just see all I the adorable
like foxes at my own pace that I think
is isn't is where it belongs more than
you know just playing it in a 30 minute
bursts I don't think you can get a sense
of this yeah sure but like for what I
play I thought it was it was adorable
the one major gripe is that the frame
rate was bad if they can address that
and make it fluid because obviously it's
giving you this massive beautiful world
to explore art style is is lovely like
like you think it looks dub I think as
you go through them through the game
further and further and like you get to
see it in like day and night and the
water and everything it does look really
nice but is it's the kind of game that
you like this is I just want to explore
it and take all in but
when it's got framerate issues like that
that kind of yeah remind you you're in a
game right yeah it makes you sort of it
makes it take you out of the experience
of being in this beautiful sort of you
know Vista with the Sun setting in the
ocean crashing again yeah taking it in
at your own pace and like said the frame
rate and things like that just ruin your
immersion yeah and on a game that its
backbone his visual storytelling an
emotion that's not exactly what we want
yeah our final game charming little game
called snake pass it's nate past my
dudes we and we did let's blow on this
last week let's play the same build to
be played at the Xbox event I found this
game yeah it's a big from this game so
you're you play as noodle a vegetarian
snake and you go through these puzzle
levels collecting orbs and keys to get
on to the to the next level it's just as
simple we said it like is it a puzzle
platformer because you know platforming
isn't the correct yeah they can you're
not exactly jumping but you can when we
when we sat down play the dev said okay
you need to think like a snake and play
like a snake yeah and as absolutely true
as well yeah that as I excuse me you
don't really realize what that means
until you've got your hands on it
because you you need to move the left
the left stick left and right to
actually gain traction as a snake like I
actually need that momentum to slither
which I thought was really interesting I
thought that like would get quite
annoying yeah but actually works really
well yeah and you've got a sort of like
hook yourself around things to complying
yeah like here like I'm about to fall
off any like oh no no no you wrap
yourself around it in like tighten your
muscles dealing sure you stay on it was
it was a great idea and there's like
little puzzle elements we are underwater
and you get to explore this world we've
been talking about it quite a lot you're
actually playing it for review right now
that's right yeah and having played a
little bit more of it now I think it can
at times get a little bit frustrating
it's surprisingly quite tricky this game
like the later levels get real difficult
and like it's basically a test of your
coordination in sort of wrapping your
hands around the controller in the same
way that snake wraps itself around a
hook or ever yeah and my coordination
is not my strongest point so I'm finding
it quite tricky but the the art and the
music and the music was his music is
amazing he's really reasonable it looks
like like banjo kazooie / ukulele it's
got that kind of yeah i mean what i like
about it is that it's sort of its aping
that sort of art style and and the mood
but it's really trying to do something
new like the sort of mechanic of
slithering is brand-new I've never seen
a game like that before no no absolutely
it's a puzzler or sorry a platformer
like no other really but yeah it's just
whether it can get that difficulty curve
right is I'm still remains to be seen
well from what I played I said this to
you and I said it to the dev it's got
that in in feel at least it's got the
same vibe that trials gave me only the
way that it's got the balance of
difficulty in satisfaction right mmm so
again with with with trials it's
obviously a very different game but the
levels were were tricky but they were
never unfair they would never never made
me angry or frustrated sure like what
we're even when I failed it still made
me wanna play more yeah half of it is
because it was satisfying and the other
half it was just that it was a really
nice place to be I think the key is is
making you feel like it's it's your
fault and not the game's fault yeah not
succeeding and I think that does it
really well because if you like if you
screw up wrapping yourself around a
certain objects like that's that's on
you yeah but we've been playing along
looking forward to your review when
we'll be able to check out I'll stay
tuned very very soon well if you enjoyed
this video make sure you hit the like
button comment down below which game you
found most interesting I'd love to hear
you guys thought especially if you've
played any of the iterations these
yourself stay tuned for more videos like
this let's goodbye from me goodbye from
Oscar goodbye and we'll see you next
time